Nabi Saleh a tiny village in the
occupied West Bank that has been waging
a sustained unarmed resistance movement
against Israel's military castle it can
show work of attorney this is the
birthplace of academi the Palestinian
teenager who confronted armed Israeli
soldiers in front of her house excluding
it and served eight months in prison
per slap reverberating around the world
catapulting her into the international
spotlight as a symbol of palestinian
resistance the normal answer for the
Israeli occupation is to slap them she's
blonde with curly hair with Keller died
that's why her case went worldwide in
the days leading up to her release I
came to Nabi Saleh to learn how his
backstory and to experience for myself
daily life in this village which is
being choked by an illegal Israeli
settlement and which suffers regular
violence from the occupation forces I
wanted to hear what lies ahead for the
young generation of Palestinians growing
up under an occupation with no end in
sight it kind of clicked on activation
with Salam monogamist alternating eyes
you
we're in the Palestinian town of Nabi
Salah and the occupied West Bank where I
had to Mimi grew up and right across the
road over there is the illegal Israeli
settlement of hala Miche in the presence
of those settlers and the many soldiers
deployed here to protect them has made
life for villagers in Nabi Saleh a
living hell
these are regular scenes in Nabi Salah
Israeli soldiers firing tear gas skunk
water rubber-coated steel bullets and
even live ammunition while unarmed
Palestinians marched carrying flags and
banners and sometimes throwing stones
for the past decade the villagers have
led a popular nonviolent resistance
movement to protest the Israeli settlers
creeping confiscation of their land and
resources this resistance campaign began
in 2009 after settlers took control of a
natural spring that's owned by one of
the elders in the village the Tamimi
family traces its roots back to Nabi
Saleh for hundreds of years more than
500 people live here most of them
extended family across the road the
Israeli settlement of henna Miche was
created in 1977 it's one of more than
200 settlements in the West Bank built
on occupied Palestinian land in
violation of international law
before you can even enter Navi Salah you
have to pass by the settlement and an
army base to protect it an army
observation balloon with cameras
monitors the village at all times
international law allows Palestinians to
resist occupation even via armed
struggle within the bounds of the laws
of armed conflict the villagers of Nabi
Saleh have chosen a non-violent path but
the Army's response has been anything
but nonviolent has life changed on
December 15th the day her 15 year old
cousin Mohammed was shot in the head at
close range by an Israeli soldier hidden
windows up the hakko in the halitosis
I mean handle it calculation work of
attorney Danny have they got so much
robbery robbery
his injuries were so severe he had to be
put into a medically induced coma and he
lost an entire part of his skull kami on
your mat saw Abbott enter shoot that
sucker she saw yeah no I can fit more
judges but I do not remember I'll coach
tonight honey fulfill the hell softly
huh
cancel today she and Cara valve in 1589
horrible transfer horrible Clutton
sorrow captain of the sofa where the
fatal Vilna who can't repeat oh it's
good what'd I do
hada cannot be then I want another Yanni
I wanna chef Natalia Lamar's hateful
this tertiary into more supporters or
even wonderfully I know of my liking oh
can I tell motor tranny was it sound
really done it man I know my Safari on a
test I sure did hi attack Trier at her
trailer can I shake here feel valid
never totally eye-fucked good but Ryan a
her hi lugar de jure
such an energy Hannah okay Lachey 18 ok
nose and burgers for Hoffa had out no I
do sensational
hours after Mohammed was shot I had
confronted two armed soldiers in front
of her family's house
the incident was filmed and shared on
social media by her mother Nettie men
who would later be arrested and charged
with incite Minh millions around the
world were captivated by the image of a
young girl showing no fear as she hits
out at heavily armed soldiers
four days after Israeli soldiers came to
her house in the middle of the night and
arrested her while filming around nevi
salah we were stopped several times by
various israeli soldiers and we were
stopped by a guard for the film a few
miles outside of nebby salah israeli
soldiers threw a stun grenade at us for
filming around a checkpoint okay alright
put the camera down
we know I don't speak Hebrew where I'm
in American okay okay
[Applause]
[Music]
like elsewhere in the West Bank
childhood for the youth of nebby salah
is anything but normal for many here
it's not a matter of if they'll get
arrested but when because of that the
adults in the village organize regular
training sessions where they simulate
the experience of getting arrested
detained and interrogated to teach the
children their rights and what to expect
during her hours long interrogation I
had remained silent refusing even to say
her name as many as 700 Palestinian
children under the age of 18 from the
occupied West Bank are prosecuted every
year through Israeli military courts
they're not accompanied by a parent and
are often interrogated without a lawyer
or being informed of their right to
silence over the last three years the
Palestinian child prisoner population
has doubled its first cousin 11 year old
salmon became known as spider-man
because he regularly dressed up as his
favorite comic book hero during the
weekly marches he liked how Spiderman
helped people and thought wearing his
costume would give him special powers
levesque Alicia I asked him what
happened to his I can addition J&I
witness so where I came from was a head
or lamb at 11 lemon sauce and Kenan
Kenan laughing for three years Casa
infinitely duck o valiant you saw it -
of the object and I know there are so
many remnants of tear gas and sound bomb
canisters left behind by Israeli
soldiers Santa's family hung them up in
front of the entrance of their home his
mother minal told me why we want to show
people who is coming that
these kind of weapons it used against us
for adopting nonviolent resistance
manal says she's been injured countless
times during the villages protests one
time even getting shot in the leg with a
live bullet and she's been arrested
three times the last time was during a
women's sit-in outside the military
court at one of Israel's prisons one
week after I had was arrested that was
the worst experience because the minute
they arrested me they took me back
behind the guard the room and they
attacked me they began to kick me and
beating me with their legs and their
rifles I didn't have any medical
treatment so after two days my face it
was like this why did they hit you when
you were arrested the last time without
any reason just days after she was
released Israeli soldiers arrested her
teenage son the homeland from their home
and like I had arrests it happened in
the middle of the night I asked minal
why they arrested him throwing stones
it's the typical charges when they can't
find evidence again it's one of the
youth or the typical thing is throwing
stones and they will have one or two or
ten soldiers as I witness stone throwing
is the most common charge levied against
Palestinian children and is punishable
by up to 20 years in prison under
Israeli military law after being
arrested children are taken to
interrogation where they're often tied
at the hands and feet denied food and
water and are physically and verbally
abused
manal says her son in Hamid's
interrogation was so severe it nearly
broke him he was kept in interrogation
centre called with a thick veil which is
one of the worst interrogation center
inside the 48 and the cells are
underground he's not allowed to see
anybody
he went from 5:00 in the morning until
10:00 at night everyday work it's being
interrogated
the room were lighting 24/7 he's not
allowed to have a shower to change his
clothes so for 25 days he couldn't take
a shower or anything only small meals of
its mashed potato like one spoon of
splash Monti potato to keep him alive
actually Hammonds brother Osama who was
arrested ten days after him was forced
to watch his brother's interrogation a
form of psychological torture how do you
feel as a mother having two sons and
Israeli prison right now it's awful the
worst nightmare that any mother could go
through that to know that her children
or her sons taking the sequences of a
decision she took and when I took the
decision towards with the nonviolent
resistance I knew that at one point my
children gonna be punished Israel's
occupation which is more than half a
century old and with no end in sight
puts Palestinians in the West Bank under
Israeli military law and a system that
denies them the legal rights of citizens
Israeli settlers living in the same
territory have full democratic rights
and are governed by Israeli civilian law
that means a Palestinian and an Israeli
settler can commit the same exact crime
but be tried in different courts with
different outcomes under the military
court system Palestinians face a
conviction rate higher than 99 percent
this dual and discriminatory legal
system has been denounced by many in the
international community as exemplifying
apartheid as part of the preparations
for ahead and her mom's return home
they're about to raise a Palestinian
flag right now I wanted to visit their
home to see how the rest of the family
was doing with half of its members
imprisoned by Israel and his older
brother wide has also been in jail since
May serving an 18-month sentence for
throwing stones her father bassam is one
of the leaders of the grassroots
resistance here he's been arrested by
Israel several times and was tortured in
jail you guys filmed that as she slapped
the soldier and you decided to
the video knowing very well that she
might be arrested she might go to prison
why did you do that where a freedom
fighter were not a victim for that yes I
know that she will be we know that she
will be arrested but we believe that
it's our part of our duty and
responsibility to encourage our
population and our society and our
people that everyone can do something
knowing that she went to jail because of
the video do you regret publishing it if
it's retained I will publish it to on
exact time you would do it again yes I
would it's part of our strategy to build
the belief of an involuntary State and
to show the world our message and if we
who struggle we must be ready to pay the
price without the freedom and without
justice and dignity there is no life I
had slept the soldiers in a normal day
it's the normal way not to slap the
soldier is abnormal why do you say that
it's normal the normal answer for the
Israeli occupation is to slap them the
normal way to deal with our enemy is
just by resistance and I think everyone
in the world every parents would like
their daughter to be strong like her not
to be broken him in front of an atom man
in the meantime the emotional scars left
on his children are evident
Bassam says his Sunnah Mohammed
nicknamed Abu Yasin copes with the
absence of his mother sister and brother
by telling himself that they're just
away on vacation I asked him my all know
that I'm asking why you don't ask he
said I convinced myself that they are
traveling outside I don't want to think
he's in denial
oh yeah but that's not where the trauma
for these children ends earlier this
year
Samet witnessed his 21 year old cousin
azzedine Tamimi gets shot and killed in
his backyard by an israeli soldier the
following footage is graphic
subversive I sell a chemical on a shovel
home office whether I know turbine
talented or conferred Allah had arsenic
at Manly wanna nozzle hegemony no Daryl
Jacob regna couldn't I fish a lot was
knowledgeable so they act like tava her
greatness truth no never on both had a
plan truth now and eyes not cool Vogel
Buffy shifter woman photography and
Joseph it
I would know Allah o Allah so rapidly my
chakras are lo TT revolution animal who
stubby and joyfulness tested
I am valve canal a mechanical baton -
motion Colleen and the ladder today
Israeli soldiers left eyes bleeding for
30 minutes before eventually
transferring him to a military vehicle
once there he was held for another 15
minutes
without medical attention the soldiers
then surrendered him to an ambulance but
it was all too late the trauma that
children like salmon witnessed is even
apparent in the games they play the only
thing they are saying the brutality of
that soldiers the suffering of their
families they saw their family got
injured the got arrested they are
thinking this is than the normal life
that we are living you will see them
either playing soldiers Palestinian and
soldiers in throwing stones at each
other or playing like now SMA he was
playing with what and handcuffed him
like he's the weakest there bearson here
and so he's like vollis Tinian we can
arrest him or we can handcuff him I
heard story has cast a spotlight on a
new generation of Palestinian youth
their plight their hopes and their
increasing influence in the resistance
against Israel's rule over them it's a
generation with less loyalty to the
different political factions and growing
disenchantment with the Palestinian
Authority whose security forces have
coordinated closely with Israel for more
than two decades what do you think I
hads generation will accomplish that
your generation wasn't able to I think
we are the generation of the First
Intifada and we all do our duty and our
responsibility we succeed personally but
I think this generation will be able to
make the
exchange they do what they believe
nobody controlled them and said it's
okay or not okay they are more free 12
year old Salam is a heads youngest
brother to octave higher dr. fluffy
hurry
Nana but a bus Martin Buber see you soon
I'm assuming I'll call a bus after I
said for your head zu Lee Min Ho while I
hads incarceration made international
headlines it is not unique last year
Israel arrested 1467 Palestinian miners
and there are currently around 60
Palestinian females in Israeli prison
many of whom have longer and harsher
sentences than I had the lack of
attention other prisoners get is a
reality that I had own family members
acknowledged God has captivated the
world partly because she is a woman
she's yeah she's a female not wearing
hijab she's blonde with curly hair with
Keller I sure she's the best example for
the European and Western girl that's why
her case went worldwide in the time that
there are Palestinian female miners
lying and are very bad situation but
nobody care about this because they are
not blonde we still suffer from white
privilege and discrimination as the
hours countdown for I head and her
mother's return home the future for this
village and for the Palestinian people
remains grim it's been almost a decade
since you guys started your marches and
protests and during these past years
you've lost so many relatives they've
lost their lives or they've been in jail
do you think it was worth it and was it
the right strategy it's not easy after
70 years of occupation to keep asking
for ROI we were right we are not because
we are the owner of this land and
the resident of this land and we are
this is our history in this land
[Music]
no it have to tell of honesty in
relationships eleven o'clock and it's
not coming Nell modern with dual well
hibachis that's why l poq recruiter at a
shoe salon I was totally lying
in part two of this series right now I
have Tamimi is released from prison in a
chaotic and emotional day I sit down
with the Palestinian teen icon to hear
what's next for her men when gypsy
hejian Ont bent to drove away agenda in
Salamanca hemolytic anemia beam and
Damon Emma Scottish a novella in no
demon ork of the booty Allah hey guys
it's Dina and that's life in nebby solar
make sure you check out part 2 of this
series which is the day of ahead Timmy's
release and my one-on-one interview with
her please make sure to like and share
this video and subscribe to AJ plus